we fought the revolution to impeach it's
idiotic of course mind-boggling
Democrats are planning to hold a new
impeachment hearing this coming
Wednesday when President Trump will be
at the NATO summit in London oh great
timing Jerry Nadler this is yet another
instance of Thun tone-deaf Democrats
trying to undermine the president while
he is abroad in July of 2017 may recall
President Trump was at a Bastille Day
celebration when Democrats introduced
articles of impeachment against him
February of 2019 Trump attended a summit
to meet Kim jong-un all the while
Michael Cohen unleashed a litany of
attacks on Trump and then in July of
2019 Trump attended the d-day memorial
ceremony in France and that's when
congressman Nadler chose to pursue more
Russia witch-hunt hearings joining us
now for reactions senior legal adviser
to the trunk 2020 campaign Jenna Ellis
house freedom caucus chairman
congressman Andy Biggs and Fox News
contributor to Roy Murdoch congressman
Biggs let me start with you is it your
sense that that Democrats are are
catching an earful back home among their
constituents and that they may suddenly
get a case of the for reals and
reconsider their drive to impeach well
in some districts they are so if you're
in a swing district like the
representative you just showed the clip
of there they're a little bit feeling
some heat some discomfort about pursuing
the impeachment and especially in light
of what came out in the last two weeks
of of the open hearings right so so so
first of all it's up to the nobody can
really explain what the charges are so
the people there are going there who've
said we wanted Pietschmann
who are members of Congress in a swing
district are now feeling the heat about
saying well you can't even tell us what
the issue is so yeah they're they're
feeling it in some respects that's why I
think they're looking for an off-ramp in
some respects if they can get what
get an off-ramp yeah well there's
there's plenty of off ramps on that
freeway Deroy Murdock you penned a
column that'll be coming out pretty
shortly and you shared it with me in
advance you write that the Democrats are
on the verge of getting what they wanted
and he'll be sorry
how so yeah I think that they may learn
to hate their little impeachment toy
which they just unwrapped among other
things their timing is horrible you know
we are now just finishing up
Thanksgiving we've got Christmas coming
and the hearings on impeachment the
articles of impeachment if they're
written the debate on impeachment all
that stuff will be going on while
Americans are trimming Christmas trees
going shopping enjoying eggnog going to
Christmas parties getting ready like
Hanukkah candles the whole country is
uniting at home doing all these warm
loving things and the Democrats going to
be on TV dividing the country and then
if they do decide to go ahead and hold
impeachment hearings most likely a
Senate trial will be taking place right
at the same time that the Iowa caucuses
New Hampshire primary Nevada caucuses
and maybe even the South Carolina
primary will be taking place which means
senators Sanders and Warren and Booker
and Kamala Harris Klobuchar and Bennet
will be basically tied up on the Senate
floor unable to do anything while they
much rather be out there campaigning so
to turn the Democrat presidential
primaries totally upside-down you know
Jenna in battleground states like
Wisconsin I note according to the
polling data 40 percent supporting 53
percent are against impeachment but
what's important is how independents are
breaking against impeachment by an 11
point margin what does that tell you
yeah absolutely I think independents are
an excellent bellwether here because you
can't accuse independence of political
tribalism and so the fact that these
Democrats are going home to their
districts and they're being faced with
independents who are saying we are not
for this we didn't put you in office to
do this the average American and the
reasonable American are seeing that this
is just a complete sham this is not what
the founding fathers intended by the
separation of powers whatsoever and for
MSNBC to run that kind of ad is
completely antithetical not only to what
our founding fathers fought for bled for
and died for but it's completely
misunderstanding and
completely negating what president
Trump's is all about and how he has made
America great again and how he is a
fighter and he is an American who has
advanced so much for you and me and for
the voters who put him in office he has
accomplished so much in spite of all of
this opposition because he is moving
forward and he is making America great
and I think that the independents are
seeing that and they are just so sick
and tired of this witch hunt and this
sham that she told the Democrats back
off you know congressman Biggs I said
recently on the air that if Democrats
are foolish enough to impeach they've
terribly miscalculated because a trial
in the Senate will not be anything like
Adams shifts impeachment farce it's
going to be just the opposite Trump
won't be on trial Joe and Hunter Biden
will be on trial along with Adam Schiff
and the fake whistleblower what do you
think no I think you're exactly right
first of all it will be every day six
days a week from noon until they finish
in the evening that's a requirement of
the Senate rules
second of all it's going to be open and
thirdly Republicans will be able to
bring in witnesses just like you said so
so look first like the hunter Biden Joe
Biden Adam Schiff the whistleblower this
shift team of staff who who worked with
the former whistleblower look for a
Redux of Inman look for the people who
work with VIN man who can further
impeach venneman you you got Brennan and
clapper you've got a whole series of
witnesses that can come in and Lindsey
Graham has promised that he would bring
in those types of witnesses and this
would be go for quite a length of time
and and indeed the the primary is going
to be turned topsy-turvy for the
Democrats this is not really the way
they want it to go that's why one of the
reasons they're looking for an off-ramp
is well I think Joey you're not in your
head over here yeah I look I think it's
entirely possible that if this meltdown
continues this may not even come to vote
in the House Nancy Pelosi is very smart
about counting votes and she sees 17 of
these trump district Democrats get cold
feet she'll find some way to say hey
Merry Christmas come back in January
vote on us MCA the trade deal and move
on and just get away from this well and
the if the Inspector General report
comes out and really dirties up obon
his FBI Justice Department intelligence
agencies that may give Nancy Pelosi
Schiff and Jerry Nadler pause to pursue
impeachment as resident he would look
more like a victim here and they'd be
revitalizing him that's it all right
Jenna
congressman Biggs drawing Murdock thank
you all thank